citizens of the
reject Nation it is John and Andrew
Gordon back in the saddle once again to
check out a David Fincher classic the
man is back in theaters with the killer
so we are finally going to check out the
classic the True Crime epic it's time
for zodiac Andrew how you feeling are
you excited I am very always excited for
another David Fincher film although I am
missing one in his filmography his
greatest film I've heard Alien 3 oh yes
definitely me too one day we'll we'll
get together guys leave three likes on
this video also don't forget to
subscribe and hit that notification Bell
so that you are updated every time one
of these videos drops and as well thank
you to the team over at prepper for
helping us chop down these highlights
it's tough work and last but certainly
not least if you want to support the
channel and Rock a little reject Nation
swag in the process go on over to reject
naations shop.com we got tons of great
stuff over there we got the Classic
tickets we got the who influences the
influencers America's ass the boys
inspired te we got Ahsoka inspired te's
official Loki te's there's plenty to
check out there so go have a look grab
yourself something nice and uh hey if
you want to get the complete experience
alongside Andrew and I see everything
that doesn't make these reaction
highlights come on over to patreon.com
theal Rejects sync up with your own copy
and enjoy the full zodiac experience
along with everything else we got to
offer over there we got tons of other
shows and films with reaction highlights
and watch alongs included it's a good
time over there Andrew are you ready to
solve some crimes let's solve some
crimes joho let's do this
thing what follows is based on actual
Case
Files the 4th of July this is literally
the song I sing whenever I leave the
real rejects
Studio Vio it's beautiful with the
fireworks yeah I love this shot in the
car where have you been I've been
waiting since 700 get in I haven't eaten
in 24 hours are you counting the hours
is that the actor who plays Minkus in uh
Boy Meets World I'm pretty sure that's
who plays Minkus in Boy me World Stuart
Minkus ah it is Minkus oh my God M kiss
I definitely know who you're talking
about did you now watch boy Meats world
I would don't know what you're talking
about Andrew I definitely definitely did
it's July how many shirts are you
wearing seriously I'm cold you're cold
on the 4th of July how are you cold
sheepers
dude nothing and die I say how are you
cold sitting next to her all those
layers going to act like a bulletproof
vest off a
die man shut up ain't nothing bad going
to happen
today uh I saw that car Mr X do you want
me to tell him to leave stay in the
car driving a Mustang that felt very
Michael Myers ask from the first
Halloween was that your husband no what
is that a real question don't worry
about it don't tell me not to worry who
was it it's nothing
what I have so many
questions ohoh let's go this is really
unsettling
o yeah cuz cops drive around in Mustangs
man you really creeped us out oh jeez
[Music]
whoa with that massive silencer yeah
that was loud too loud silencer I mean
silencers are a lot louder than they are
in movies but oh
whoa oh that's a tone Setter yeah that
was harsh I want to report a double
murder if you go one mile East on
Columbus Parkway to the public park
you'll find kids in a brown car whoa I
they were shot so many times it's a
miracle they're still breathing
whoa that's not a real recording was it
I would assume it was but I don't know
goodbye come on
buddy I swallowed it why it was
minty am I we got the science Bros and
Mysterio
hey the crossover event of the summer is
this a Multiverse film I knew it cross
event of whatever year this came out
2007 of Pion speakers for $188 oh wow
and you got Striker Brian Cox from X2
that's how David vure cast this he was
like I just want all the different
Marvel
people oh Elias cotas got Casey
Jones oh dermont man Derm we
got Scream Six in the house yeah quite
an All-Star cast also too I think it
said Chloe her I forgot how to pronounce
her yeah she's from Boys Don't Cry or
the one with Hillary Swank you better
get this right Andrew I know Kimberly
pierced her everyone's counting on you I
know Kimberly Pierce directed the film
that came out in
1999 Boys Don't Cry I'm going with that
gotcha
boy it really got the Aesthetics down
and the and the set designs I I love it
it must have been so so much fun to go
on
set editorial
too oh please rush to editor nope nope
nope nope Paul what's on the crime beat
Janice hey in datebook left the fun you
party before everyone got naked fraking
Janice
oh my
God this is the murderer of the two
teenagers last Christmas at Lake Herman
and the girl on the 4th of July near the
golf course in bleo to prove I killed
them I shall State some facts which only
I and the police know oh brand name of
ammo Super X 10 shots were fired the boy
was on his back with his feet to the car
woof here is part of a cipher the other
two parts of this Cipher are being
mailed to the editors of the valo times
and SF examiner in this Cipher is my
identity if you do not print print this
Cipher by the afternoon of fry f r y
first of Aug 69 I will go on a kill
Rampage fry night then move on to kill
again until I end up with a dozen people
over the weekend wow does that look like
a Gunsite oh sure is this Vallejo story
true do we know that Paul what I cover
crime in
Vallejo yeah I cover crime in val oh
jeez get it together man R Smith don't
you have a cartoon to
oh yeah yeah you're going to be real
real Handy on this case man all the
Zodiac cartoons we can get two teenagers
on lovers lay both the OA David Faraday
and Betty Jensen July 4th darling faren
and Michael M I think it's Mayu anyway
he lived oh boy oh he lived the examiner
is going but won't go front page we'll
go on page page four what do he say 20
bucks whoever cracks the psycho's name
he won't keep his name Mor anyone
Morty
mores mortis well done that's not Grim
foreshadowing yeah the cipher is broken
into three sections each with eight
lines and 17 symbols woof Greek ORS code
maybe semaphore weather symbols
astrological signs whoa hey take again
there at this code thing
okay I love the way we're hopping around
right now yeah it's a lot of information
looking at this you were right by the
way you didn't give his name who cracked
it a history teacher and his wife Selena
nice more fun than killing Wild game in
the forest because man is the most
dangerous animal of all that's what the
Predator always says the most dangerous
game when I die I will be reborn in
paradise and all that I have killed will
become my slaves what what is that at
the bottom leftovers maybe an anagram
O come on man been here 9 months it's
time to earn your your clout how did you
know he wasn't going to give his names
are you him another letter details about
the murders he taped a flashlight to the
gun that's how he hit him in the dark
and he gave himself a
name zodiac this is the Zodiac speaking
I've heard those words before but at
some point the county decided that the
land would work better as a lake
so they flooded it there's an entire
hidden city under the water Atlantis yep
yep Jason M Mo's down there right
now I know everyone's probably sick of
my comic book references at this point
but we need some DC ones Fincher is
clearly favoring the MCU yeah
right this is watching us oh we're very
goodl
[Laughter]
looking oh
jeez did he go mask up or was he masked
before I it's hard to tell God he has a
gun jeez I want your money and your car
keys okay oh
man oh man you're welcome to everything
I have if there's anything else I could
do for you maybe I could write you a
check oh boy oh
God here's the
case don't get
up I want her to tie you up
it's fascinating the way they are
lensing the killer this is cruel like
it's so striking the way that they shoot
him okay you all
done you know just cuz people are going
to ask was that thing even loaded Jesus
oh no no you don't want to find that out
oh yeesh it's okay no it's not this is
all going to be okay it's not I don't
like no oh
yeah oh my God this is so brutal
wow
no oh boy this is Zod wrote down wrote
down all the dates of his deletions a
Carmen gear I want to report a murder a
double murder they are 2 miles north of
Park headquarters
they were in a white Volkswagen carp Gia
I'm the one that did it who was that
there WR in the dates on the side of the
car you got two valo killings now
there's one in Napo why Napo interesting
that the male keeps surviving and the
female doesn't each time hell a get him
I wrote it it's done now I just got to
type it up type it up it's not until you
type it up we got to read I love that
he's always like semi slacking gra so
Boy Scout he doesn't smoke he doesn't
drink he doesn't curse and he's back so
he's Superman he just does puzz he is
the most dangerous game a movie about a
account who hunts people for sport yep
yep we've got curfews in effect tonight
for the following counties Nappa salano
Contra Casta Alam Marin and Sano the
cinematography it's phenomenal so far
like the way he zoomed into on those two
uh victims before they got stabbed yeah
the perspective especially in those
scenes is very striking we have good
solid communities out here in the North
Bay unlike in the city where you have
Satanist running around well you bring
up a good question is the
Zodiac I just talked about the
cinematography and then they do this
they I think the bigger problem is how
do they this is before drones helicopter
shot yeah cuz this is before drones
interesting point so what do you think
he'll do
next oh jeez it's like the second I saw
the way his face was shadowed I like bad
things happen I know the way it was lit
I'm like yeah why are they not showing
this person's face and why are we in a
taxi right now well and not to downplay
the fact that we've shot this taxi very
uniquely but what is your location 339
at Washington at the corner of sh one
done can we think he's robbing him also
too it's yes please H just showing how
random all these uh murders are it's
just like there's no particular pattern
you got him doing a bunch of couples
keeping the males alive and then a taxi
driver
like wake
up whoever this is you owe me a new lamp
don't make him
angry I'm always angry well it wasn't me
I've been with my bride all night she
can vouch go put on the
folders part of waking up let me just
describe the lamp you're going to buy
me how do they do do that with the lamp
falling right next to the camera like
that was they had a PA right there
seriously that was amazing walked off
the cab and secured the crowd
seriously and everything cers no I'm
rooster it's your Daddy thank you you
ever tried Japanese food what do you
mean like Teriyaki no like the urchin
raw fish I'm eating here
Bill jeez the victim's name is Paul
Stein except pronounce him at 1010
suspect fired one shot to the back of
the
head any Witnesses kidss who called it
inide the suspect from that window sure
got him as a white male glasses crew cut
stocky wearing a dark jaget wait I
thought someone said it was black that's
the description that went out to radio
cars we already corrected oh well that's
good I mean that's going to mess up
somebody's night real bad body or scene
it's your birthday I'll take the
body happy birthday the odd thing is we
also got gloves suspects blood
on yeah buddy I got a single 9mm caseing
[Music]
whoo yeah Luger hope he calls up and
tells you the brand I'm a shooter negro
male adult who also happens to be a
stocky KW cut
Caucasian I give him this address did I
give him this address who's got the
fairbook Washington and maple it's one
block east he's using a different
caliber every time different gun also to
he knifed down the uh uh other couple as
well
so there is like an element of chaos or
Randomness yeah but it also seems like
vaguely intentional I don't know I shoot
him on the right side he slumps right
maybe you've got your hand on his collar
when you shoot all right so either way I
just don't record a blood in the front
seat so why do you get in the front seat
o why do you get in the front seat I'm
an idiot but you're not an idiot you
waited for him to put it in park yeah
and you're like doing out ciphers and
uhoh what do we have
here ug don't put your hands all over
that this is the Zodiac speaking I am
the murderer of the taxi driver over by
Washington Street and Maple Street last
night to prove this here is a
bloodstained piece of his shirt that's
why he got into the blood so you got in
the front seat to tear off a piece of
the shirt is this uh on the record what
do you think it confirms the healings
gets worse Robert you have a
deadline you got some cartoons to draw
School make nice targets I think I shall
Wipe Out the school bus some morning
just shoot up the front tire and then
pick off they come bouncing
out threat on school children we don't
want to start a Citywide Panic so I'm
asking all of you to please keep This
Confidential still going to send your
kid to school I'd feel so uncomfortable
right now with that threat ah dude kids
got to be exposed to the harsh reality
so that they can grow a thick skin in
life you know Pat your carrots and your
Cel peanut but okay D you don't have to
wa with me I know yes I do more than
ever son oh paranoia you know what you
know what I'm going to drive it today
okay motor pH Baker Hall see a
handwriting
and that is you waiting in the hall if
you speak again I have to
concentrate sorry sorry comes to
speaking you're making me impatient you
wouldn't like me when I'm impatient we
have to release the bus threat it'll
screw us we just went from routine cabby
shooting to mass murder targets
kids wipe out a school bus and pick off
the as they come bouncing out oh yeah
bud damage done it's it's the tropy
movie thing perfect timing it's
fascinating how they're positioning the
gyllen hall character in this cuz he
does feel like an eyeline even though we
haven't Laton homosexual jeez it's like
we have this eyeline even though he's
not like directly super involved with
the main plot yet right right dmit
Moroni that's the Zodiac Killer my dude
we we saw a specific horror film that we
knew him to be a killer we're going to
need tell him we got the entire force on
this how many men can you give me I'd
like to set up a meeting with your
Survivor Michael I can't he skipped town
the only guy who seen zodiac without a
mask is missing when he was still in the
hospital we could show him lineups all
day long soon as he got out he split I
don't blame him bootprints to and from
the crime scene were made by size 10 and
1 12 Wing Walkers military style boots
sold only at military pxs wa did you
guys narrow your list off of this yeah
did Vallejo I don't know I don't work in
Vallejo I work here
jeez man everyone's having a day look
I'm just trying to get us coordinated
have you called Sal Sheriff's Office why
did I call salano cuz the two kids that
got killed as Christmas were solanos
they were over the county line so you're
going to need to coordinate with them
too is great this is a team effort here
I love the monotony of all this
coordination of all this
disorganization yeah everyone passing
the buck everyone's got a fragment have
been murdered in the San Francisco area
and in each case the oh WIP out of
school but oh San Francisco oh it's
driving him insane is there no music he
shoots the cab then takes them off
there's the first attack J and Betty
Jens they both die they and out he only
manages to kill the girls not for like
of trying not for lck of trying weird he
gets so caught up with the women he
forgets to finish off the men couples
and all on love his
Lan single male cab driver on Washington
and cherry doesn't fit doesn't fit
exactly wow is it a copycat but it it
seems like it was him he's breaking the
pattern yeah he's resetting the Paradigm
it's either random to break the pattern
or to copy someone claiming to be zodiac
called Oakland PD a half hour ago call
in on Jim dunbar's Morning Show in Hours
on television he wants Melvin B on to
counsel what his wife must be so
regretting marrying a police officer in
homicide at least this man has asked for
my help man you're worrying about
stuffing you out
what are these
cookies oh Brian Cox BC headache powder
if you see an opportunity we want you to
suggest Old St Mary's Church in
Chinatown you'll be tring the call
Pacific telephone says you need to keep
them on the line for 15 minutes no
pressure yeah geez 15 minutes is a long
time oh back in that day yeah no when
you're in an intense situation 15
minutes is an eternity no matter what
the time yeah get the tape Jim we have a
call we're going
live
hello hello this is Melvin belly who am
I speaking with this is the Zodiac
speaking so unsettling and do you think
you need Medical Care medical not mental
do you have health problems I'm sick I
have headaches oh God I have headaches
too but a chiropractor stopped them a
week ago I think I can help you Sam we
just need to get some bones cra reckon
for you we're not tracing these calls
you have my
word okay you've convinced me with that
one sentence do you want me to do that
Sam do you want me to talk to the
district
attorney oh my God we had a scream that
was my headache oh boy or you're causing
someone else a great deal of pain I'm
going to kill them I'm going to kill
those kids fantastic oh my
God so Eerie let's meet and talk just us
how about old Mary's Church in Chinatown
no in front of the Daily City St Vincent
the Paul at 10:30 I'll see you there
damn brave soul out here my my you
fellows certainly know how to put on a
secret
meeting yeah anity is the is the key
word here voice is too high too young
all right thanks for coming down Brian
do you have black oh that's the guy who
got stabbed at the lake wow trade
fertilizer 1 gallon of stove oil it's a
bomb okay we got to call the Army and
see if this science experiment con
actually work another
Cipher you married uh divorced like that
kid's in the hall two kids my name is
secretly Quinton Beck this can no longer
be ignored what is that you're drinking
it's an Aqua Velva we're getting that
next time we go out to the bar oh oh
yeah Aqua
Velva but
actually bonding love it we are
definitely getting that drink now face
it Ray you're a girl drink
drunk what's the most common double
consonant in the English language
consonant L Double L yeah one word that
we know that he'll use in here at least
once kill kill right yeah but how do you
go from a is one and B is to to figuring
out this whole cut well same way I did
you go to the
library what's the library then I found
a code written in the Middle Ages guess
what it's called the Zodiac alphabet
who there's not many basement in
California basement for future use I'll
have Leo and Napa check with their city
planners sleep going by committee now I
like it that is a good call on the
basement thing I've always wanted one
being a c California resident I am
finding it extremely difficult to hold
it in check and I'm afraid I will lose
control again and take my ninth and
possibly 10th
victims it is a cry for help intended as
a private communicate which is why you
contacted the chronicle the people have
a right to know sure toddy yes please is
that eggnog love a hot
toddy
interesting Modesto wow I've only been
there once this is going to end
well oh Jesus no please
no don't stop don't stop don't do
it oh
[Music]
no I wonder the whole thing with the
doctor makes me wonder cuz the guy they
were talking to on air they were like
his voice doesn't match and if he keeps
contacting him maybe it's like somebody
else no oh boy is said I own a sky right
rear wheel is loose really if you like I
could tighten the lugs up for you if you
don't mind well you can't be too
careful such a good use of these
perspectives limited perspective oh no
damn it
no no no
no oh my
god oh have a good night
[Music]
all right now skirt let's go move it
floor it
go you loosen the
nuts yeah damn it no no no no no no no
no Jesus
[Music]
no must have been worse than I thought I
can give you a lift to a service station
uh
okay oh this poor woman oh my God too
trustworthy I didn't know you had a baby
oh is that okay the more the merrier get
out of my
car she smoking with the baby you
shouldn't smoke it's bad
habit and we just drove past the service
station I think we just passed a filling
station it was
closed
oh my God before I kill you I'm going to
throw your baby out the
window what what about the baby what
happened to her she said she done from a
car I found her like this you said it'll
be okay what about the baby my baby
where's your baby she didn't have one
when I stopped where's your
baby oh my
god wow you did it in case he came back
oh my God she jumped with the baby out
of the car that must be it wow thank
god oh thank
God what a transition give her this very
trustworthy but she's her Survivor so is
the baby going down five rows and left
looking for the Modesto B from March oh
Modesto that's where he snatched the
woman and her baby officer Richard rtic
shot sitting in his car soia claim that
he shot someone in their car couple days
after this article came out the police
already had somebody in custody zodiac
didn't do it it took credit for it
anyway huh he even stole his symbol what
no uh if I show you something you
promise not to tell anyone who would I
tell okay no one listens to me I'm a
cartoonist that's the only place that
word in that symbol ever appeared
together before the letters gu stole his
logo off a watch I think somebody who's
killed he claims he's killed 13 people
but which ones can we actually confirm
there's three in Vallejo one in Bera the
cabie that's
it a mind trip yeah maybe uh we drove
him
underground maybe he's gone all solid
conclusions boys definitely happy
birthday Bill oh it's his birthday again
he had a birthday last year I didn't
realize the passage of time had been a
year oh yeah time's flying Darlene bar
killer is brought to Justice uh Darlene
the woman from the very
beginning
Jesus no oh no tell me that's not a
piece of bloody I feel it in my
bones you ache to know my name and so
I'll clue you in but then why spoil the
game you did call him a late and
homosexual in at least one of your
articles I want a gun M yep yep yep a a
gun lots of guns Just build yourself an
Iron Man suit you'll be fine you are
doomed as a result several Crown newsmen
are wearing lapel buttons reading I am
not Paul Avery
[Music]
wow yeah but this is 1970 do are you
going to know what Paul Avery looks like
I mean there's no internet database to
look up what someone look yeah most
people wouldn't I bet they're counting
on that I'm working on you know the
Zodiac yeah I'm working with you know
who Paul Avery is I work near him and
and he's going down toight to track an
anonymous tipster down in Riverside
giving up a lot of info here it's near
La oh wow almost that it's that far away
sounds kind of dangerous are you trying
to leave this date right now to go down
to Riverside well you said it was an
anonymous tip right so it could be an
ambush it could be the Zodiac yeah do
you have any change oh my god oh wait no
wait hold on you got make a call and
when you said it was dangerous I just
thought that it is dangerous and it's
stupid stupid and and I just thought
that I should call his wife and just see
this first date is just going perfect
it's everything you hoped it's a start
of a beautiful marriage well she said
she'd call when she heard from it okay
yeah want to go back inside Melanie I
should really should go home and wait
for the call God damn it is some sley
plan to get me to go home with you what
no no I don't want you to come with me
at all get out of here I'll get the food
to go damn it worked oh wow
what this this is so sketchy my guy this
is sus to the ultimate degree at least
have the gun ready I'm supposed to beat
somebody
here dude at least take somebody with
you as well n bro why are you
shouting you sitting down yeah you're
not going to believe this whoa a 1966
Southern California murder that Avery
now believes was the Zodiac's first
victim what damn killer wrote to the
Press letters that I then took
personally to the office of question
documents damn now his face is out there
what I knew in my gut Rong the
handwriting matches
Z looked to the camera emphatically how
do we know that this this lead is real
it's very real you know how I know cuz I
saw it on
TV yes everything you see on TV is real
so the public boy she studies in the
library the night of October 30th
1966 her body's found the next morning
in a parking lot stabbed to death
oh I'm not sick I am insane but that
will not stop the game this letter
should be published for all to read it
this could be our boy God there's so
many that guys in this movie like so
many character actors double postage
just like zodiac these are what sure
would moral match to the Zodiac letters
H these in the desktop done looks like
kid handwriting this was found a couple
of months later by a janitor in RCC
storage oh wow if red clean blood
spurting dripping spilling well does
that match the writing I also told him
we don't think this is zodiac okay wait
a minute you don't think this is zodiac
we got a guy we like for it then why
give anything to Avery I'm trying to
cooperate that's how you cooperate by
giving information to
reporters this is just a crap show right
now well I love you the illustration of
the tension between the press and the
police does it matter that Riverside may
not be able to a case against her
suspect because of you tell to Sherwood
I'm out here beating the bushes trying
to draw them out we're in this together
we're not in anything together oh hey
bullet been a year and a half you're
going to catch this guy or not yes go
yourself happily you should have
call one moment please I mean I get it
he did he was scared but he kind of did
go over their heads in a lifethreatening
situation you know you do create crazy
impulsive things well and two when when
you're you know when you're in the game
bastard like Andre could have done
something like cut off all the victim's
hands zodiac didn't cut off any of the
victim's hands Travis and I work here
side by side for 10 years his foot gets
crushed in an accident and the killings
begin is that Jeff Daniel Phillips he's
in a bunch of Rob Zombie movies he was
the Geo caveman good actor he said it'd
be easy cuz there'd be no real motive to
the thing then he said he'd write
letters to the police and and call
himself zodiac to mess with them talked
about shooting out the tires of a school
bus and picking off the Little Darlings
Le's into skin diving I know he's been
up to that skin diving first recorded
contact with the police department about
Allen was uh in cabona January 10th 1970
he just got lost in the shuffle did chny
have anything against Allan did Alan
screw his wife or anything I mean it's a
it's a legit question he he misspells
words like that he thinks it's funny
what about the hand writing I don't know
don't you have experts for that stuff
yeah question document says it's
inconclusive maybe he did it with his
other hand the letters are a little too
need for someone to have written with
the wrong hand yeah some of the he's
ambidextrious he can write with either
hand he writes the Zodiac letters with
his right hand producing a different
handwriting that he can't be linked to
whoa make sure you call MX it is his
backyard all right because that works so
well for us in
Riverside
it seems too simple no they solved this
this is going to be fine oh it's over
the film's
done kind of lumbering have you ever
read or heard anything about the Zodiac
when it was first in the paper but I
didn't follow it after those first
reports I told all this to the other
officer what from Vallejo it was right
after the murder at the lake and what
did you tell this
officer uh that day when I I came home
my neighbor saw me neighbor's name Bill
white he died a week or so afterwards
heart attack so I didn't think to call
to follow
up sure the knives I had in my car with
the blood on them that blood came from a
chicken that I killed for dinner this
just got interesting I had knives in my
car that weekend maybe Bill saw them and
called the other officer on me well
we'll be checking in on that were you
ever in Southern California at any time
in
1966 is this about the Riverside
yes kind of watch forant says that
you're ambidextrous my teachers tried to
make me when I was a kid but I couldn't
I'm left-handed he also said that you
made statements about school children
that is oh that's the horrible thing to
say so you aren't angry about being
fired from Valley Springs for your
students
ug this is so unsettling I'm not the
zodiac
and if I was I certainly wouldn't tell
you I mean that's a nice watch thank you
oh the Zodiac watch right the logo came
from the Zodiac watch right we're going
to find out yeah it's a
Rolex where'd you get
it it's a Christmas gift from my mother
two years ago of all the
watches oh the most dangerous game
that's why you're here is it it was my
favorite book in high school it's about
this man who waits for people to Get
Shipwrecked on his Island yeah man is
the most dangerous animal of all that's
the whole point of the story oh yeah we
read that in high school as well did you
really uhhuh I didn't we read Romeo and
Juliet and Hamlet there you
go I mean right now they just have
circumstantial evidence they don't have
any actual evidence but they have a
legitimate M suspect I mean
[Music]
damn not saying it's him but that was uh
quite an intriguing conversation zodiac
letters that were sent you'd like you to
take a look at them you think my
brother's the Zodiac oh my God it's Stan
Winston Jr Matt Winston oh is his son
yeah I didn't know he was an actor yeah
he's the beauty pageant host in Little
Miss Sunshine at the end here where he
spells Christmas with two s's we got a
Christmas card from Le a couple years
ago he spelled it the exact same way
Chris Mass back to we encounter
yeah this suspect is not your zodiac I
mean we know he's ambidextrous in 38
years I've never seen anyone that
ambidextrous really I me this is so cold
this case we need alen's right hand we
can't get it without a war are there
other guys you should be looking at only
what
2300 okay
then let's uh start back over find the
hay in the needle stack you wrote the
justice department asking to be put in
charge of the zodiac investigation one
year later Clearing House to promote an
exchange and free flow of ideas and that
you run it well who better than
me the mocked
Man One Stop boozing two stop doing
whatever else it is you're doing and
three cut this nonsense out no more
cocaine you feel my excellent work is no
longer in step trashy provinal rag more
than happily to camp for greener
pastures all I mean
is my man's needs to start a band Avery
and The Marked Men last year we arranged
for Lee to get help from a social worker
he couldn't talk about a former patient
so I just asked him straight out if he
thought Lee was capable of killing
people because of patient
confidentiality the man said yes woe if
not we get his prints and handwriting
samples from both hands I'm sure would
shut you down what if I can get a second
opinion if the suspect is ambidextrous
could he possibly have written those
letters with his other hand get the
samples of his other hand if he's the
Zodiac you'll get a match sure meanwhile
I spoke to a psychologist someone who
under go a personality change like
zodiac would manifest it physically
altering his handwriting which is why
Sherwood couldn't get a match fromal in
samples like actual Alters like think
he's got multiple personality disorder
maybe this is a Santa Rosa Police
Department we have a warrant to search
your
residence oh
no what ises he is he dead his rodent
FR my man skip
[Music]
town dude this trailer's even got a
skylight neighbor said he tore out of
here about half hour ago you think
somebody tipped him we're not leaving
till he comes back we live here now and
he never came back I'll check the
back
all the squirrels shouts out to little
Ricky rest in
peace Jesus What
squirrels and he been in the fridge
piece of work this guy yeah I guess wowe
this must have been a fun day on set not
one but two blue windbreakers and a pair
of black they wearing are they wearing
are they wearing gloves right now men
seven just like the ones we found in the
cab no they really ought to be Jesus
they're just touching everything
both 22s one automatic one revolver
that's interesting CU he happens to have
an M1 rifle here oh yeah that's right
there was a Luger uh in the cab right
yeah hello out there remember us tiny
little shorts oh they called him Arthur
too they didn't like that are you guys
the squirrel catchers yeah it's Animal
Control it's not your
suspect no ug ballistics no match prints
no match writing no match he's not your
guy
wow we were so
sure did the Zodiac like know about this
guy just like he's yeah he's like so
kind of perfectly positioned it's and he
had the Zodiac watch too of all I know
it's probably a popular brand at the
time but still four years
later Adam Goldberg oh snap this is like
an allar cast Adam Goldberg has entered
the game is he taking over for Paul
Avery or just another person at the
chronicle honor to leave the chronicle
and go work for the Sacramento B here A
Dream right
Robert did you just Dro me off of my
place and take the car you should keep
the car I'm not coming in tomorrow or
ever again I'm done what I put in for a
transfer what dude how's Maverick going
to fly without Goose dude this is so
zodiac gu is like messing with all these
people's lives and brains and all
[Music]
that
persy the boys need to be tucked in
please and the baby needs changing
[Music]
okay flower
power I got to watch you play sometime
are you in a b not yet ah one day oh
hey seen that mizing oh yeah my own kids
would kill me for one of those M I feel
like what what's happened to Paul is
what would have happened in Jaws to
Quint if they wouldn't have caught the
shark and they survived
sure if you put all the information
together maybe you could jog something
loose and then I was thinking that
nobody knows the case better than you
you have all the files yes a no what do
you know that more people die in the
East Bay commute every 3 months than
that idiot ever killed he offed a few
citizens he wrote A Few letters and he
faded into footnote Michael Myers killed
three people in 1978 it's four years ago
go looks like the dude right now you're
wrong it was important he's he's getting
there he's just needs to CW his hair a
little longer but he's getting there you
hovered over my desk you stole from
waste baskets am I being unkind
[Music]
oh it's interesting though how um Mark
Ruffalo and Jake gyen they just will not
let it go though I'm still fascinated by
the positioning of the gyllen Hol
character oh nice thank
you is that was where that cab just
parked that wasn't the exact spot where
that was it that's where the cabie yeah
cuz the kids were watching from that
window up there ah that is so
everybody's looking back over the cabie
scene I wanted to ask you about Zodiac
Zodiac hasn't written in 3 years you
know how many murders we've had in San
Francisco since then no over 200 so
nobody cares I care sure where Cypher
everything an amateur would need to
create it to be found in these books if
you can track these books then maybe you
can track the man so I went to every
Base Library and I got a list of every
person who's ever checked out these
books he should make a cartoon about the
Zodiac also that I mean I wonder if he
would have had to at some point it means
they were stolen every book on ciphers
was stolen from the pridal library and
the Army terminal Library oh now the
wheels are turning I can't discuss the
case with you I can't give you
information and I certainly couldn't
tell you to go see Ken NLO in Napa hey
he my man thank you for not telling me
that my man I understand his position
he's like I can't s again these these
aerial shots I love it dude Fincher you
are killing it what are you some kind of
Boy Scout Eagle Scout I was actually
first class if you want to do this don't
let me stop you better start with
Vallejo Jack mol we have so many comic
book actors in this movie you realize he
was in Blade and Ghost Rider oh sure is
that uh Donal log Donal log yeah no pens
no paper anything that you see that's
relevant better remember in your head
okay remember in your head photographic
memory
on this is
interesting
who ooh The Sounds yeah it's like the
mix of of him reading along and and
their chatter from you remember at the I
know this is a random thought but do you
remember at the very first scene where
the two the couple got shot she wouldn't
reveal who it was she's he's like who
was that she's like oh it's nobody or
something that M yeah like I still want
to know what she was she wouldn't say
feel like she knew
him strange man strange strange man
strange
man oh yeah
jeez write down everything he just
processed cup that water between your
fingertips damn he's actually doing a
great like I've tried writing on napkins
like not easy rip them up yeah did
anyone ever get in touch with Mike mou
during your investigation and show him
suspect photos he's the only surviving
victim whoever saw zodiac why you asking
me m and Darlene that's vallejo's case
Paul Stein is mine got four minutes
stuff yeah she and her husband they move
into their new house and and one night
they throw this painting party what's a
painting party it's a party where people
come and help you paint sounds like a
terrible
party that's not a party at all and
Darlene is terrified of so you think
that Darlene knew zodiac said yeah
zodiac knew Darlene and maybe Mao know
zodiac but Mao's gone so if you want to
connect Darlene to zodiac you're going
to have to find another way there were
four other calls there were two to
Darlene's house one to Darlene's
brother-in-law and one to Darlene's
father-in-law just just heavy breathing
and this is before anyone in the family
knew that Darlene had been shot whoa so
either zodiac shoots a random couple
then he recognizes Dar or Darlene was
shot on purpose whoa I that's what I
literally just said to you cuz she
wouldn't reveal remember to yeah she
knew she knew something about who that
person he said to her who was that and
she said oh it was nobody like she
wouldn't say who it was yeah she clearly
re or knew something we didn't know
zodiac calling people at home he did
that in San Francisco
what who did he call I can't tell you
that's privilege information but but
maybe Melvin Bell could I love their
Rapport yeah it's that's who he called
you mean to Mr B about the case no to
the Zodiac when he called he said he had
to kill because it was his birthday what
day was this when was this so many years
ago Mr Bella was away for Christmas the
Zodiac called wanted to talk to him so
he was born around Christmas so
Christmas day or the week before
Christmas I have to kill today is my
birthday then the letter arrived so the
call came before the letter of December
20th so is that the 18th how do how do I
confirm it well if my partner did talk
to someone from Justice then they would
had to put that in report that standard
procedure call the
doj the report like he said why would he
volunteer the day he was born Bill
Armstrong checked this out none of the
suspects have the same birthday as this
Phantom caller y Armstrong can I give
you a piece of advice stop you're
looking in the wrong place handwriting
fingerprints that's what this whole
thing is about stick to the evidence yes
that worked for us Robert graith has
quietly been shopping his book about the
Zodiac well that's what the article is
about I'm not so sure that's something
we want people to know about why are you
embarrassed no put it together he
targets people he reads the chronicle
yeah but he's never going to re herb
Kane oh no no no no no no no no no no
yes awesome mentioned in the today yeah
I can tell you who the zodiac is a red
herb Kane the Zodiac Killer is obsessed
with movies he recorded his murders on
film I tried to tell the police but they
wouldn't follow through on it what he's
a friend of the zodiacs Mr vau does not
know his friend is a killer and he's
storing some film casters for what
Zodiac's name is Rick Marshall what why
would you give this information okay
well who is it that's giv his first
letters he executed the K with two
strokes later letters he did them with
three why we don't know wow about a
month ago a man showed up at my doorstep
very distraught uh name was Wallace
Penny he said he knew who the Zodiac was
give me a name whoa Rick somebody Rick
Marshall yeah I never cleared a Rick
Marshall oh good
excellent
hello uh
hello who is
this it's black
Christmas it's the wrong number hell
yeah definitely I was expecting a heavy
breathing call thank you now I got to
wait for them to call back does the name
Rick Marshall mean anything to you you
just named my favorite suspect in the
whole case love this guy I handed him a
photo he looks at it he's about to give
it back and he stops and he says my
goodness I got fingerprints all over
this and he wipes them off huh Rick
Marshall was a Navy man he received code
training who was also a projectionist at
a silent film theater O damn how do I
get copies of rck Marshall's handwriting
three ways get a warn which you can't
two get him to volunteer which he won't
three yeah yeah get to it get creative
that he is I need a sample of Rick
Marshall's handwriting I I told you van
Mr
Penny Rick used to draw movie posters
for the theater Von worked at I'll send
one down thank you you know what instead
of of getting handwriting and
fingerprints just do heavy breathing
tests on everyone sure that will solve
it yes that will be the The Smoking
Gun on the poster the one letter that
absolutely positively does not match is
the letter K damn it I was looking at
the ks and they don't look that
[Music]
similar oh his new part it's interesting
seeing all the chess pieces falling off
the chess board and then seeing Jake
Gyllenhaal take a more active role in
their oh yeah their uh Parts jenning's
here from The Chronicle came in this
morning and you need to see it right now
see what a new zodiac letter and it
mentions
you it mentions you this is the Zodiac
speaking I'm back with you tell herb
Kane I'm here I have always been here
these guys are from internal affairs I
want to see head shots oh about his
rapport with Jake jenal think not only
is this new letter of forgery but it was
written by the very man trusted to hunt
down this killer David tsy what he
believes tsy wrote the letter to drum up
publicity for himself yes definitely
agree we've been running handwriting s
who who Who's we Sherwood and I Sherwood
who drinks like Paul Avery now he
retired oh no you know what the chances
of arresting someone are now too much
time has gone by okay too too much of is
lost God zodiac was my job it is not
yours and whose job is it now he's still
out there D no Robert I am through with
this I am through with
you nah you can't stay away I get he's
just trying to do the right thing but
it's just having a profoundly bad effect
on everyone one day before the vernal
equinox Dad yeah Mark that oh got
another on June 19th 1971 oh my God are
they helping him yep got a whole team on
the case don't tell Mom about our
special project okay oh my God while
they're watching Flintstones nothing
like bonding over True Crime with your
children we've been cross referencing
lunar cycles with the Zodiac's timeline
each cycle since' 69 corresponds with an
attack with one of the letters or an
unsolved homicide
sh what's
this in the decad since the Zodiac's
last Cipher was received yes oh boy yes
a cartoon
has succeeded my man oh uh just a lot of
books from the library and um I love
puzzles so I I just oh my God I know
what that's like doing the oxygen mask
he we found Linda she's in jail isn't
that great what' you do it cuz she'll be
able to identify Rick Mar uh have the
kids went on TV oh yeah dude it's a real
bad idea who's been calling our house in
the middle of the night at least once a
week nobody dude you cannot ignore that
I need to know know who he is I need to
look him in the eye and I need to know
that it's him oh no dude why do you need
to do this cuz nobody else will that's
not good enough are you done can I go
there going to be papers on your pillow
tonight you needed to speak to me why
don't just go to my home oh I I don't
want to put you out it's no trouble do
you need to screw the my tires too yeah
yeah you should check all my lug nuts
you
know step
we've got Roger Rabbit in the
house please Charles Fleer he's also in
Nightmare on Elm Street at the dream
Clinic the doctor and Back to the Future
Part Two save the clock tower do you
remember the Zodiac this is about Rick
Marshall isn't it well yes there is a
connection between one of the zodiac
attacks and that film you mean the
symbol what the first time I saw it in
the papers I thought about that what oh
huh Rick left a a film canister here
that he told you never to open
tip the poster that Rick drew the
handwriting is the closest that we have
ever come to a match Rick didn't draw
any posters I do the posters myself oh
damn it oh no oh well this is going to
end well why don't I just find out when
we play that film but that's all right
it's not a problem they're just down in
the basement
yep not many people have basements in
California I do follow me would
you the original Studio One sheets I
always kept for myself I mean he said
he's very curious to find out who it is
oh man he's been sent on a wild goose
chase ran in May
69 9 weeks before the first zodiac yeah
do you think think he saw the film in
our theater and was
inspired just delivering this all from
the Shadows oh yeah but do you remember
that shot in when he was in the cab how
he was covered in the shed oh sure no I
mean it's very suggestive I mean giving
you an opportunity just to examine his
voice thanks for everything you're
welcome check out some of these film
canisters ah check the locks sir it's
great use of that
mirror thank
you Jee my dude God that was so
suspenseful and one hand you're like
keep your cool but the other hand you're
like how could you keep your cool oh I
would I mean I wasn't even there and I'm
freaking out yeah you'd be tearing out
of
there bad
news empty
house took the kids and went to Mom's
uh-oh you you put the family in danger
we shall leave you papa the Zodiac
kidnapped my entire family she leave a
note like a note right there it's a
cipher took the kids to mom moms don't
call oh yeah but wasn't the the his son
that was his son though right the one
from the begin before they even started
well you know she's mom
now oh is this Darlene's sister I guess
so oh it's um it's I don't know this I
know I've seen this actress before I
just don't know her name I know her name
damn tell me about this painting party
all the cops about that so long ago I
don't even remember it people get old
Darlene always had a lot of boys around
even though she was married this one guy
was weird though so she was a it rhymes
with a mut oh took me a second but I got
it
promiscuity yeah I was just kidding it's
my poor attempted humor we don't mut
shame Here Andrew I'm so sorry she once
told me he'd killed somebody and Darlene
told me to stay away from him she was
scared of him a couple weeks later she
was dead yeah that is Eerie do you
remember his name it was short like a
nickname Rick no I don't think so how
can you be sure it's a long time ago
think hard this is what happens they're
all obsessed it wasn't
Rick it's like I lost my family over
this what damn it man's is I've got
nothing it was Lee oh
wait is that the guy with the squirrels
yep wait she was she had she was with
Lee that guy that's what she said I mean
I'm not saying she would just give me 5
minutes I know exactly where it
is come back at 8:00 a.m. she having a
hard time like I'm not saying a woman
would not be interested in an well and
you never know he could have been more
dashing before he got moved around and
into trouble Lee who used to bring
Darlene presents from Tiana that's just
one name in a file that contains
hundreds it's nothing my investigation
into this subject is over sorry you're
not sorry at all cleal that's her name
got it isn't she in a movie where like a
video game comes to life it's like a
horror film maybe stay alive I forgot
what it's called think she's in the
faculty she's in a bunch of stuff I
never saw the faculty that's the horror
film right who's there she's in
Argo Argo f yourself yep you don't
return my calls out I've been kind of
busy you told me not to
I tried to send you
these you've been served nothing makes
sense anymore did it ever can I just
serve you these divorce papers please
yeah the kids miss you can't even see me
like this neither can I so do whatever
you have to finish
this that's morbid go to her here's your
divorce papers fix yourself go to
her oh okay not divorce papers
oh
God is he a cunning suspect this like
are we going linguist with this what are
we doing our birthday was the one time
that he was weak the one time that he
gave something Robert I am calling the
police it's Arthur Lee Allen oh you
liked him from the start dude you did
where didd you get that
name December 69 I need to kill today's
my birthday it was his birthday Arthur
was born on December 18th
dude knew they should have had Animal
Control get those squirrels 2500
suspects the only one who ever wrote me
a letter with Leon they like to help you
know sometimes yes Robert I know I told
you when the lug nuts thing happened I
was only thinking of that actor I told
you that that was before we even saw him
I'm sorry I wasn't your man and it's
typewritten using a typewriter is not a
crime and he knew Darlene Ino
files that's a and he knew so much in
that com conversation we were like this
is a very yeah that you spend two years
on them and that nobody ever came close
all the evidence said no Sherwood
disqualified his handwriting the same
Sherwood that drinks like Paul Avery now
well because the writing was it was from
Roger Rabbit that's why right sure yeah
that's how he was able to beat them with
the handwriting because there was no
evidence Robert what do you mean there's
no evidence you have him seen with the
ciphers the military bootprints the same
size shoes and gloves the most dangerous
game the Zodiac watch bloody KN all
circumstan that's why I told you most
circumstantial evidence you get nothing
concrete you interviewed him at the
refinery on August 4th so he's cleaning
out his trailer he's moving it to a
different County 48 hours after he
interviewed him that's not sus no he
just wants to start a new totally normal
and when did the letters begin July 69th
after the murder of Darlene faren now
after that do any of the letters contain
swatches of Paul Stein shirt no because
he dumped him cuz he got scared cuz he
knew that you were on to him when's the
next letter from zodiac January of 1974
Paul Stein was the tax tax driver then
in 74 he feels comfortable again because
everybody's moved off Allen as a suspect
three new letters from zodiac in January
May and July in 74 this all sounds logic
what happens to Alan he's
arrested we don't get another letter
from zodiac the entire time he's there
oh wow Allan gets out he types you an
apology and then what we get our first
new zodiac letter in 4 years wow Jesus
that is compelling again it's still
circumstantial but that is very
compelling darling Fen worked at the
Vallejo House of Pancakes on the corner
of Tennessee Okay Arthur Le Allen lived
in his mother's basement on Fresno
Street door to door that is less than 50
yards M Jesus so he ate there I can't
prove this it's still circumstantial
because you can't prove it doesn't mean
it's not
truey dirty
hairy the movie they met that's our
thing now
[Music]
yeah
1983 so this all started in ' 68 wow
this is yeah this is wild a long time to
uh pin it on someone nah dude this the
black Dolly all these are going to get
solved like any any day now oh Jack the
Ripper they're going to figure all this
out ah yeah but he's going to know what
he uh Lee's going to know exactly what
he looks like can I help
you
no
oh it's a great little change in
expression 7 and a half Jesus
1991 wo boy the timeline in this film
John and Andrew have entered the game
yes we are alive and ready now been
alive for a second oh my man's a selling
yes I am a crystal 3 years old at this
point
now oh we got a Jimmy Simpson damn I
think the only movie I've ever seen him
in was l user with Jason big if I
remember correctly man is a terrific
actor he's also on it's always sunny oh
I don't I never saw that one
Westworld Mr Melle oh thanks for coming
to see me damn that's from the very
beginning the actor who played Minkus
sure with Darlene but obviously
different actor now I'm going to show
you a group of photographs now the
person that shot you may or may not be
among these photographs all right just
tell me which one is your time you don't
recognize anyone that's okay I that
would not be easy 22 years
later he it's him how sure are you
pretty sure damn last time I saw this
face was July 4th 1969 I am very sure
that's the man who shot me8 out of 10
very
sure
wow
wow of course of course damn a partial
DNA profile did not match Allen was
developed from a
33-year-old
whoa still
open wow dude he's still the only the
prime and only suspect Arthur Lee Allen
inspector David tsy retired from the San
Francisco Police Department 9 he was
cleared of all charges he wrote this 197
that's good I wonder how he got empo
those cigarettes yeah Robert gry Smith
lives in San Francisco oh that's
good damn oh wow not one call since
Allen's passing jeez but did he get back
together with his wife it just says that
he's got a healthy relationship with his
children so doesn't necessarily mean
that their mother's stuck around yeah I
mean you know um first of all Fincher I
mean directed the hell out of this movie
and I love the way he used the camera
and certain POV shots and oh Lee Norris
so it was steuart minkis from boy Meats
world I like that they credited I guess
they had multiple actors playing the
potential zodiac here did I didn't see a
lot of sense yeah they had a zodiac one
zodiac 2 smart like so yeah they they
probably had different statures for
different points in time it makes sense
to do that because again they didn't
officially have someone in real life
that they caught too so you it's smart
to actually do that as well well yeah
plays into that whole again you're
you're you're taking people's accounts
everyone's got a slightly different one
and you're passing through time so like
this person's stature is probably going
to change a little bit over that course
like yeah such great little observation
of details totally you know for me like
obviously when it comes to a murder
mystery Crim solving Thriller obviously
you know you the most interesting aspect
of the film is always solving the case
of course like and I wanted to know who
it was obviously we saw who our Prime
Suspect was of course but I found the
most fascinating aspect of this
film the ramifications of what trying to
solve the case was having on everyone
trying to solve it oh yeah um just like
from you got Robert dowy Jr's character
you got uh goose and uh the Hulk and
then you got uh Mysterio like again just
seeing like how it's just disrupting
obviously you got fear and paranoia you
know they just want to solve it so they
can go back to their regular lives and
do their normal thing of course so they
can go focus on other atrocities yeah
exact exactly exactly but again just
seeing the ramifications on what it's
happening on their family and daily
lives I found that to be the most
fascinating aspect and from that
perspective I just like I felt like you
know the Zodiac Killer was winning in
that way like hey he's disrupting these
people's lives in an awful and negative
way well yeah he says that thing about
being in control now of everything
and in a way I mean he is it makes sense
because wow look at all these
Consultants too uh yeah yeah CU it's
like obviously the the victims suffer
the the very worst anguish uh and their
families and and whatnot but it is a
testament to yeah just how much you know
you can absorb you know the heart like
the hearts minds and and you know nerves
of so many people and obviously makes
the most sense to Center this around
both the journalists and the officers
investigating but it's one of those
things that yeah kind of absorbs
everyone you know everyone is aware of
this everyone's watching the news
everyone's paranoid that they might be
next or they might run into somebody or
some weird off-color situation is going
to lead somewhere terrible and then yeah
when you're looking in on the people
actually kind of investigating this you
see just the level of intense Obsession
that has like that has to exist like you
have to be tenacious to go after
something like this anyway but also this
is the kind of thing that yeah like how
could you not become consumed by it and
obsessed with it and and yeah I I really
enjoyed the way they
portrayed that through all the different
characters especially you know yeah it's
I think you pointed out at some point
you've got so many people kind of
entering and exiting the chessboard and
kind of doing their best and and of
finding out what their limits are and
and you know everybody seems like only
um Goose only only him only he seemed to
be able to get out and just go on with
life and the rest of these guys on a
positive note yeah are are sort of
consumed by this and uh and yeah to have
Jake joen Hall who's there from the
beginning uh but in you know these
little fits and bursts he's not really
the focus until like halfway through the
movie when uh when um you know Avery
leaves and and it's freaking Adam
Goldberg was in one scene uh two scenes
two scenes his opening scene and then
the scene where he's calling Mark
ruffalo's character to let him know the
Zodiac had written another letter yeah
but for all intens of purposes we have
like one exchange meaningfully with him
with him and Jake Gyllenhaal and uh yeah
but but then for for Jake Gyllenhaal to
be sort of the longest enduring like
he's kind of held out of everything
because of his position at the paper
obviously cartoonist we don't really
need you that much unless you're helping
solve these
one
ofed popular theories and whatnot and uh
and and yeah like this is the kind of
movie that makes me like this was
already so
engrossing I shudder to Bro the prospect
because I I've I I know a couple people
who are like very deep down the rabbit
hole of of just you know interest in and
and I guess morbid fascination with this
case and it does make you want to go and
look at all the details and and kind of
break it all down but I thought the way
that they handled it here was was well
done because it is about the greater
circumstan it's about the whole picture
it's not just about relishing in these
atrocities and like when the murders
take place they are striking they are
Stark they are harsh but uh I feel like
this does manage
to avoid did the exploitative quality
that a lot a lot a lot a lot a lot a lot
a lot of movies based on real life
Killers succumb to ultimately is like
it's didn't become too much of a geek
show and I feel like the way they shot a
lot of those sequences in particular
like you are there with you know these
poor victims and it is so eerie and
you're never quite seeing him like I I
think they did a really nice job with
the perspective and it really feels like
something cobbled together
minus you know certain small moments
here and there uh where you're like well
I don't know who would have recorded
this but yeah like so many little things
feel lived in and and yeah and and like
this was probably incred like I would I
want to know how long it took to get to
the point where we could roll camera on
this yeah you know cuz so much research
would have had to have been done yeah
for sure and when it comes to Jake
Gyllenhaal's character I like the theme
of obsession how it takes over and like
just how he's losing himself uh just
like he's getting his kids involved on
the case everybody especially yeah
because he because obviously we see that
he's got this Rapport between him and
Mark Ruffo which I love where he's like
and I would tell you not to go see this
person I would tell you not to go see
because officially obviously you know
he'd lose his job fees telling a
reporter to tell him uh to do these
things so anonymously he's doing this
but uh yeah know those rapports between
him and Mark Ruffo were great so he gets
his kids involved but again um that's
why I said like I found it so
fascinating to see like just how
Obsession was taking over at this point
because he's just he's got to know who
this guy is it's like it's not even
about the solving any like I mean from
my perspective it's not even about the
solving anymore it's just the
ramifications of seeing what it's doing
to society and and our main characters
at this point um so I found that to be
fascinating um also too I just really
thought just uh just from a cinematic
perspective I love the way uh the
cinematography was and this there were
some tracking shots too where we were
that yeah like again this is a little
it's 2007 so I a little before drones uh
you know using drones as cameras uh so
some of those shots where they were
tracking over the car and then turning
with it to where are we in terms of of
motion tracking image stabilization
because that was impressive cuz cuz now
yeah you can you can digitally through
various means like lock a Target and
have your camera always keep that Center
and I'm sure that there was at least
decent technology for that at the time
but I do Wonder cuz yeah it's not quite
as like 2023 you could do the yeah you
could just like you know get a phone and
a drone and you're done you I I would
assume too that zodiac book that we saw
by uh graysmith is that the character
Jake Jon Robert gr I would assume that
the book we saw there at the end in 1991
I'm assuming that's the real book that
he wrote in real life that's got to be
the book this is B that James Vanderbilt
wrote and by the way James vanderbild
great job I love the script that he
wrote and two scenes that really um I
mean all the whole movie stood out to me
but two scenes that really stood out
that that first scene they had with Lee
where they were interrogating him at his
work like felt like mind Hunter maybe
you want to go watch mind Hunter yeah
there is that scene um and then uh just
that the scene where it was extremely
suspenseful at Roger Rabbit's house yes
I was just again it's it's I mean it's
not exactly it's it's a it's a murder
mystery crime thrill and I know you can
make a case there's horror elements to
you know being in a film this is a
horror I mean True Crime to to me is it
is horror the horror of life and and I
mean people True Crime is bigger than
ever people love True Crime but that's
the stuff I struggle the most with in
terms of like stuff that gets under my
skin and freaks me out yeah of course of
course no I mean I've watched plenty of
uh what's the uh what's the show on um
I'm blanking right now on Unsolved
Mysteries not unsolved I mean I did
watch that too it's uh the one where
they were Forensic Files uh I watched so
many episodes not because I wanted to
cuz you're taking notes for your future
career exactly yes no sane person knows
as many movie references actually I
found fasina and this guy was a film he
was a copile yes I found it was you yeah
thanks jonald I found Fascination in
just like how police officers and
forensic teams like just work together
as a team and the scientific uh process
that went behind it in solving uh you
know the murders and also handwriting
stuff yeah and all that but also
fingerprints and all that but also to
like the psychosis and what goes on and
obviously clearly people who do these
type of things are just they they need
mental health I mean they have obviously
mental problems and like why are they
doing these types of things it's just
like that was the my fascination with
watching those types of shows and I
really also uh love the Rapport and the
different types of Teamwork because
obviously they were completely on
different pages at the beginning cuz
when we saw Goose's character he's like
he's like oh do I need to be on the
phone with it oh I guess I got to call
this oh I guess I got to call valo I got
call to like I mean maddening but also
really fun and watching them I like the
way they pitched that CU they could have
drawn it out and made it like this
conflict and at first it is and it's
like jurisdiction and people stepping on
each other's toes and people are like
well my work is sound don't you know
come at me all suspicious like and and
then yeah watching this network form of
here here are all like the main um you
know bureaus and departments and and you
know police police stations and stuff
that are working on this and here's your
little web that later Jake Jo and Hall
is going to spend all his time bouncing
around between you know it's like really
well laid out in terms of the geography
and the characters and I think the way
that it continues hopping through time
it like it it moves through time in a
way that I found really compelling that
you might you know if you're not paying
too much attention you might get lost
during but I thought this was it
enhanced The Experience greatly and I
think that I mean something like this
has to be so so hard I would imagine to
script oh yeah especially and I thought
the way I mean obviously Fincher is a is
a pretty Master director and this seems
to be I mean I again I haven't seen the
full fil MOG uh but this does we still
need to see Helen 3 yes this does seem
like an agreeable sort of Pinnacle in in
some ways in terms of his his
filmography but but hats off to the
writing for yeah not making this too
overwhelming too convoluted too hard to
keep track of uh and for whittling down
what I can only assume must be so many
details and speculations because one
thing I I don't know a ton about the
actual case I have had people you know
kind of walk me through some of the
basics and a few of the major theories
and from what I know there are many
compelling and strange details and other
suspects and theories as to who it could
have been um it did make me curious that
whole bit where he's like writing
himself where toski is like writing
himself a couple of these letters uh
that's something I would like to go back
and kind of look at and unpack not that
I'm saying like oh he did it but I'm
just like oh what a weird detail um but
yeah like this has a this is a terrific
Ensemble I thought the way that they a
cast wow oh yeah like their main cast is
great their Supporting Cast around the
more like household name Ensemble like
all these different really recognizable
character actors and and stuff like
really well uh every step of the pro
like you know living from the' 60s to
the '90s spending much time in the 70s
like I thought all the production
designs the costuming all that stuff was
really terrific the hair yes oh yeah
those those side Burns of Mark ruo yeah
no for sure and also too and I know that
they were filming The Dark Knight at the
time that this was released in 2007 Dark
Knight came out in 2008 but I feel like
this film was definitely a little bit of
an influence on The Dark Knight for sure
and also obviously it was a major
influence on the Batman Well you
certainly certainly the Batman I mean in
terms of Riddler's character and all
those obviously the Riddler you know he
delves into doing riddles and all that
it's obviously just a character trait
but like after having seen this film
like there's a a lot of influence of
this film um which is fine on the dark
night well and well I just I would say
Fincher I I think it's more fair to say
there's Fincher influence this came out
way too close no no no no I I meant just
the the flincher influence and just
maybe from the book just like maybe
Nolan could have been a little bit influ
like maybe read it and just gotten some
of that I also mean just in terms terms
of the Joker just like I'm playing into
your fears and paranoia and like like
just that type of thing and like into
onto society and from that perspective
and like deling something that's going
to whip everybody up that's that's all I
meant on that I mean obviously like I
don't think no one watched this movie
and go oh okay now I got to scramble my
scrip we I mean because they were
already kneed deep could there's no way
that could have happened unless he was
like Shar da yeah exactly exactly
because at the time of this release they
would Dark Knight was probably just
about done filming or pretty close to it
so I I don't mean in that I just mean
there were there were I I just mean in
terms of the zodiac like just how he was
like causing so much fear and paranoia
on society I just mean that from the
Joker's perspective I just feel like
there was a little bit of possible
influence there yeah there's probably
like a serial killer salad yeah but
obviously this movie definitely
influenced the B the Batman with Robert
patson definitely there was some
influence there oh 100% I mean that that
movie is like absolutely
and I mean you know the Riddler is
certainly as the Joker the
Zodiac they they co-oped his uh you know
either film C in or crosshairs or
whatever with the question mark like all
that stuff yeah yeah but uh really good
film Fincher direct of the H James V
Vanderbilt great script I love the way
cinematography was used the music uh the
way certain shots are lit the POV
perspectives I mean there's a lot of
eerie shots they're really good at
playing up the suspense and giving you
Moment Like guiding your focus to like
okay is this voice
similar oh this person's face is now in
Shadow for this and I'm sure when you
watch and repeat viewings you can go or
just kind of rewind pack which obviously
we can't do on a reaction but just when
we were on our own time like okay is
that the voice of Dick McDonald here you
know kind of thing um but uh Rick uh RI
uh no I'm talking about the actor who
plays Lee did you see the founder with
Michael Keon no oh he's one of the
McDonald's brothers that's why I say
dick McDonald um but also to the other
standout scene I was really quick I just
want to go to the other standout scene
was the one where they were piecing
together how it was Lee I really love
that scene I was like again it's all
circumstantial but it Sound Logic in
terms of like there are so many yeah
there's so many details yeah I'm like
this is really like you didn't hear
anything from this guy while this guy
was entirely in prison on top of all
this other evidence that sounds really
sound logic I'm like yeah this is I was
a very compelling argument is all I'm
saying but nothing that actually sticks
enough court of law without actual
evidence which is the other maddening
thing is you're like oh my God you can
have it's the good and the well it's
because yeah sorry sorry go ahead no
it's the good and the bad thing about
how our laws it's the problematic thing
about how our law works because there's
so much that maybe thankfully for
certain innocent folks who look
suspicious you can't yeah it just go
like there's a lot of evidence pointing
this way we should just book but at the
same time you're like God damn it like
like this is the guy but we can't we
have no actual evidence to stick him but
I I believe at least from my
understanding at least like fingerprints
wise they couldn't get him and then
writing W and then handwriting wise it
just unless I was misunderstanding it
seemed like Roger Rabbit seemed to be
the person involved in the closest match
they ever got was the posters that they
that in that exchange he found out oh
you drew those and not well you
know not this Rick guy or whoever
talking about right and there was a hint
that there could be possible or copycat
I mean part of part of me wonders though
like what if you knew that they would
analyze that and and intentionally found
some other way or found I don't know
made somebody else right like I don't
know there's so many questions still
that remain from that um I had I had one
more thought in my head but and then
interesting timing that he got a fatal
heart attack right as the police were
coming to question him after that uh
Minkus who is now older and played the
actor who you said that I forgot his
name from losers and Always Sunny uh
points out it's him this is the guy
coming to question him fatal heart
attack of course timing timing is
impeccable yeah yeah it was all part of
the plan he just he faked it and got off
the grid it's all part of the plan well
certainly guys leave us your thoughts
down below what did you think of the
zodiac what are your theories if you
crack the case great film great film
terrific film uh yeah leave us your
suspicions and uh hey before we get out
of here let's do a quickie patron of the
day shout out for let's see I bet one of
our patrons could be the Zodiac kill who
do we think if anybody at our patreon
could be the Zodiac Killer I think it
would be Eric H the last guy you would
ever suspect def you know he's got such
a gregarious personality he's got the
big real rejects tattoo hiding in plain
sight they did say it was a cynophile so
that's true he's a cynophile and he
probably has pretty nice handwriting to
I mean you know he may live across the
country now but I don't know where he
was living in the the you know the 70s
you know I don't know if he's even old
enough but but that's not that's no
matter all right we we got we're on to
you all right Eric and uh you know one
of these days you're going to be exposed
but hey no matter what happens we
welcome you as a super sexy reject and
you know even if you do get locked up
for these heinous murders you know you
should uh keep your pledge going that's
all I'm saying so uh we love you buddy
and we'll catch you on the next one be
well and uh yeah cheers much
[Music]
love